The jogan Experience how do you feel
talking about all this stuff being this
prominent public figure who's a revered
athlete you know like less revered now
well not really not when you kick ass
they let all that [__] go all that Co
[__] they let go as soon as you got back
on MVP I was two time MVP during Co
exactly they had to shut the [__] up
when it comes down to the performance
yeah you know and then over time I think
a lot of people that demonized you
especially the fans they realized you
were right yeah well I don't think all
of them will entirely admit that but
right um in the back of their head they
know you weren't nearly as nutty as they
thought you were yeah I mean I think as
more research comes out there's more
papers published in very reputable
scientific um Publications that talk
about you know all the things that I I
was kind of stopping for and talking
about I think in the end there's a you
you're on a decision you you stand for
something you stand courageously for
what you believe
or the opposite side of that is uh
either saying nothing or being a coward
and I wasn't willing to do that now say
whatever you want about the way I went
about doing it
um in the end I made a decision that was
best for me and I'm going to continue
talking about this stuff because it's
important to me and I don't want uh the
memories to be lost I don't want what I
went through to get uh brushed over um
and also I don't give a [__] you know
I've I've been able to make a ton of
money playing a sport that I'm really
good at and I'm thankful for that uh I
have a platform some people want you to
just shut up and be throw a football and
that's fine but um I think there has to
be certain voices of reason and many
people say I'm an idiot I don't have I'm
not smart I got attacked for my
intelligence levels which interesting
angle to attack me on there's a lot of
things you can say about me but um
that's that's interesting angle to go
but in the end um I believe that what I
did and what I stand for uh
is uh is a tough position to be in but I
think it's important responsibility to
continue to speak up and use my voice um
to give other people the permission to
stand up as well because there's a lot
of people that believe a lot of the
things that I believe in that don't have
the opportunity to do it don't have the
courage to do it don't have the platform
to do it in and I feel like I can speak
for some of those people and hold the
line for some of those people regardless
of what kind of crosshairs that's put
that puts me in with certain media
members you know they want to shut me
down on being on Mac fee they wanted to
shut me up from well that was the Kimmel
thing right well that no you talk that
dude have you ever talked to him I've
been on the show years ago
[Laughter]
yeah would you you would you ever have a
conversation with him in person of
course yeah of course yeah I
mean they wanted me on to be on the show
go in the summertime after I got traded
really um there you know obviously been
some things that he had said about me
that made me go I don't know if I want
to do that I'd rather you know maybe
have a side conversation first Iron some
things out um well also I don't think
that conversation is a conversation that
should be held in front of an audience
in five minute chunks like they do on
television yeah that's a conversation
that you have to let air out I want to
know why you think the way you think him
you know sit down with Jimmy why do you
think the way you think why would you
think that it's okay to say that it's a
real simple thing the people that have
been vaccinated you treat them and the
the people that took horse goo you know
rest in peace Wheezy really is that
really how you feel like people that are
sick from a disease that was created in
a [__] lab that was funded by our own
tax dollars that's how you feel like
those people should just die because
they don't trust the government or they
don't trust R the pharmaceutical
industrial complex that's been
responsible for lying so many [__]
times they're literally criminal
organizations that have the some of the
biggest criminal fines in in in the
history of this
country and that all of a sudden they're
the ones we're supposed to trust the
Liberals were always the ones that were
anti- big Pharma they were the always
the ones that had no
trust yeah anti- big Banks all that and
then all a anti war yeah all of a sudden
the ideology shifts because so many
people are compromised by this very
thing that we were talking about before
the very thing that they use to control
the media in terms of the news they use
it to control the media in terms of late
night talk shows and monologues as well
it's the same influence because the the
same sponsors the same people are
spending the same money on the same
networks and it has an impact if it
affects your livelihood and affects your
future and your ability to do this thing
that you love doing which is hosting a
talk show and you're doing it on a
network that is paid for by that money
guess what that affects you if you don't
think it affects you look what they did
with the number one guy on TV news tuer
Carlson they fired him he was the number
one guy and they're like you're getting
too crazy why was he wearing that outfit
is there uh an explanation for why CLA
Schwab was uh dressed up I think he was
on Epstein's Island
was
he no he probably has his own Island
yeah yeah it's probably under the ocean
sorry I'm not accusing Mr CL Schwab of
on Epstein's Island why did you bring up
Jimmy Kimmel when that whole thing was
going on uh I had said on the mcavee
show before they had talked about you
know forever they talked about releasing
the Epstein list or whatever and I had
said that on the show and he had got on
his show and called me a 10 f 10 foil
hat-wearing you know doofus who
is talking about you know there in I
thought he had said that I'm an idiot
for even thinking there's a list that's
out there what was he saying you're a
doofus for
thinking that the list was going to get
released I guess I don't know I don't
know what that doesn't make any sense
why would anybody defend the people that
apparently were on that list because it
is a real list yeah there was something
a conversation that Pat was having about
about this list coming out and were
talking about as a distraction to
something else and I and I was referring
to the list being that there being a
list and it coming out he might have
said might have been thinking that I was
trying to connect a distraction that was
going on with a list being released so I
just said you know so when you were
saying that he doesn't want that list to
come out you weren't saying that he was
on that list no okay see that was a lot
of people if they saw it out of context
they know nobody watched the [__]
clip that's why they just saw a headline
very oh the anti guy again let's [__]
Hammer him right but but if someone saw
that out of context you could see how an
I thought that you were saying I saw it
out of context I thought that you were
saying that Jimmy Kimmel was on that
list because a lot of celebrities were
on that list well the list hasn't been
released yet but whatever list was one
test one text of like one victim's step
there's a hundred victims nobody's
gotten you know you talking about people
going to jail no one's gotten to jail
you know who who I mean glain Maxwell
was ARR charged and in jail for
trafficking to nobody right which is
wild yeah like look and I said this when
I when I back on the show like that's a
big [__] accusation that I wouldn't
make and I said Jimmy I'm glad you're
non list and all I'm asking is let's
have the same energy yeah for you
talking about the vac and people if
you're not vexed just being left to die
about these people on the list cuz it's
[__] up and what goes on at the top of
this [__] and why people were going to
ep's Island and all the conspiracies
about whether he was a Massad member and
galain and her father and all the weird
connections like yeah I'm I'm for all
corruption in all forms being taken down
I don't give a [__] if you're on the
right side on the left side whatever
like expose it and especially if you're
doing crazy [__] like that to kids like
[__] it seems like it was an
intelligence operation it seems like if
you had to guess they were compromising
powerful and influential people and they
could use that to control all sorts of
narratives yeah and to make all sorts of
decisions